todas las redacciones de france 24 se
movilizan para llevarle el directo la
elección presidencial estadounidense
sobre el terreno en seis de los estados
clave nuestros enviados especiales
estarán con quienes decidirán la
elección desde carolina del norte
pasando por georgia florida arizona
wisconsin hasta pensilvania france24 le
propone postales de campaña una cita
diaria con los eeuu de hoy el 3 de
noviembre estaremos en todos los
noticieros con nuestros corresponsales
para seguir las últimas horas de esta
carrera a la casa blanca la gran noche
estadounidense una transmisión en
directo minuto a minuto para seguir y
analizar el contenido siga en vivo este
histórico evento en las señales de
france 24 en francés inglés árabe y
español y en nuestros sitios web y
aplicaciones móviles
[Música]